dans moins d'une semaine ce campus sera
beaucoup moins calme et 3000 étudiants
du collège heureusement débuteront leur
cession mais en plus de leurs cours ils
devront suivre une nouvelle formation la
formation et elle est obligatoire pour
l'ensemble de la communauté collégiale
et les sessions d'informations sur les
violences sexuelles
donner aux étudiants et au personnel
enseignant les mesures contenues dans ce
projet de loi reflète notre volonté
collective de mieux soutenir les
victimes devient elles sont obligatoires
à compter du 1er septembre pour répondre
aux exigences de la loi 151 de l'ancien
ministre hélène david une loi n'est en
à la suite du raz-de-marée mitu qui a
secoué la planète des réalités peu
reluisante ont été mises en lumière
et ce jusque dans les établissements
scolaires selon v1 et claro ces
formations seront offertes sous
différentes formes possibles que je la
nomme en présence c'est sûr que
actuellement tous les cégep rosemont
compris réfléchissent en formule pour
être davantage en mode web
les établissements devront aussi
accompagner les étudiants ou les
enseignants en cas de besoin donc par
exemple
le policier l'a pas le faire va pouvoir
venir en civil pour prendre une plainte
dans mon bureau avec étudiante revenant
que ça soit le cas donc c'est un
partenariat auquel je croyais beaucoup
mais on est claerhout crois aussi qu'il
faut impliquer directement les étudiants
ont souhait c'est de pouvoir vraiment
mettre sur pied un comité d'étudiants
parce que je crois vraiment aller aux
actions posées par les pairs il faut en
mesure aussi de des témoins la
fédération des cégeps entend travailler
avec les établissements et le
gouvernement pour assurer que tout se
déroule rondement avec certaines les
retours sur ce que les gens font on
regarde ce que ça donne comme résultat
les gens partagent ils ont réinvesti
cette expérience-là et ultimement il est
prévu aussi confronte reddition de
compte donc au ministère pour ceux qui
ont déjà débuté les classes ailleurs au
québec les mesures sont bien reçus plein
milieu de jeunes ou ce que beaucoup de
l'intimidation
beaucoup de jeunes s'entraînent aussi là
dedans puis se motive mutuellement dons
c'est bien de prendre le problème à la
source un chauffe c'est une bonne idée
surtout c'est dans le but de prévenir et
éviter ce genre de problèmes surtout
c'est comme une priorité
une priorité qui dorénavant devra l'être
pour tous ici elisa céret radio canada
montréal